que eu acho engraçado em televisão é as
propaganda de televisão tipo a
propaganda eleitoral interrompemos a
nossa programação para a transmissão do
horário eleitoral gratuito horário
eleitoral gratuito aí eu paro e penso é
claro que é gratuito quem já boar a
pessoa no mundo que diga rapaz minha
televisão tv acaba é completa ou assinei
foi tudo é Sport TV éu FC Big Brother eu
assiste o Big Brother horário eleitoral
gratuito eu comprei foi tudo então acho
que eu vou ficar sem ver o a propaganda
da Dilma tu é doido é vou pagar meu
amigo não existe essa pessoa aí o
horário eleitoral ele passa tipo em
todos os canais só que tem uns dois ou
três que ele não passa a diz Beleza vou
assistir o que não é horário eleitoral
muda neste governo eu vou realizar
várias reformas muda neste governo eu
vou realizar muda neste governo eu vou
realizar muda neste governo eu vou neste
governo muda neste governo